there's one episode of america's history  that is told very differently  depending on who you are and where you  live it is the story of our civil war  and what came after we have not  adequately understood who we are as a  nation there's a big movement to  remove confederate history i don't see  the pain  in this symbol i don't think that  slavery and jim crow should be forgotten  i'm gonna disagree with a common idea  that the civil war  was totally about slavery  you don't really hear the word slavery  or slaves in mississippi  the simple term is whitewash  in that reconciliation the nation itself  embraces the confederacy all of this  tension and anger comes from the erasure  of  african americans history we all should  learn the real history because  we think we know but we don't  you